différents j'ai 40 ans j'ai deux enfants
je suis un autodidacte je suis un
entrepreneur et je suis un mec heures
j'ai grandi dans les années soixante dix
avec tintin et star trek avec l'idée que
le futur serait différent que les
voitures volerait et qu'on aurait des
bases lunaires et qu on voyagera dans
l'espace
pourtant pendant longtemps j'ai cru pour
être différent
il fallait dire merde à tout le monde à
ses parents à ses profs à son patron
métro boulot dodo tout ça c'était pas
pour moi à la fin des années 80 alors en
pension mes copains écoutait du rock du
rap du reggae la chanson française moi
j'étais différent j'écoutais de la
techno la techno cette musique née à
détroit capitale de l'industrie
américaine la techno dont les inventeurs
se réclame d'un livre et d'un auteur
alvin toffler et son livre la troisième
vague
ce libre et il l'a écrit à la fin des
années soixante dix avec sa femme heidi
est dans ce livre alvin toffler explique
notre futur quasiment notre présent
l'ère de la troisième vague c'est celle
du savoir du savoir partagé distribuer
autour de nous dans les objets dans dans
la société aujourd'hui vos téléphones
vos ordinateurs
tout ça sont plaints de savoir tout ça
sont plaints de mémoire et sont tout
autour de nous l'ère du savoir remplace
celle l'ère industrielle
et et toutes là toute la société est en
train de basculer
après le bac je suis allé travailler
parce que travailler c'était être
différent mes copains les étudiants moi
j'allais travailler j'ai commencé à
travailler dans la musique dans un label
de musique électronique d'abord puis
j'étais embauché chez warner puis j'ai
monté ma propre agence
et pendant des années j'ai fait la fête
de new york à kuala lumpur dans les
boîtes de nuit et j'étais différent et
ça plaisait aux filles
jusqu'au 11 septembre
j'ai pas vous étiez le 11 septembre
j'imagine que la plupart d'entre vous
s'en souviennent moi je sais exactement
où j'étais et ce jour là ma vie a changé
le projet sur lequel je travaillais
depuis plus d'un an une grande tournée
avec des dj de detroit dans toute
l'europe est tombée à l'eau puisque le
12 septembre leur pays partait en guerre
et que plus personne ne voulait venir
faire la fête en europe pendant trois
semaines on était à 8
c'était différent il a fallu que je
trouve quelque chose d'autre à faire et
ça a pris un peu de temps
ça a pris plusieurs années à peu près
jusqu'en 2005 d'ailleurs où j'ai
commencé à travailler après plusieurs
expériences dans la décoration et j'ai
créé en 2005 une agence de décoration
d'intérieur gt2 habile de mes mains
je t'ai pas décorateur mais je pouvais
prétendre l'être
j'ai découvert un logiciel de 3d
différents assez facile à apprendre avec
lequel rapidement j'ai pu dessiner un
club j'étais designer quasiment
instantanément
mais avec ce logiciel jeu pouvait
présenter à mes clients et aux ateliers
avec lesquels on travaillait les projets
sur les que les propositions qu'on leur
faisait et pour apprendre ce logiciel
j'ai passé mes nuits sur internet sur
des blogs sur des forums à parler avec
des gens du monde entier d'expérience de
pratique de techniques de difficultés et
il y avait toujours quelqu'un pour
répondre alors des gens s'étaient
c'était vraiment formidable et j'ai
découvert un nouveau monde est un monde
différent et j'ai de la modélisation en
trois dimensions j'ai découvert ce qu'on
appelle les machines à commande
numérique
ça m'a fasciné les machines de
fabrication digitales des machines qui
permettent de partir d'un modèle en
trois dimensions d'un meuble de cuisine
et de fabriquer sur avec des outils
piloté par ordinateur
j'ai découvert un univers de sites web
où on pouvait apprendre à fabriquer ses
machines soi même ses machines qui
jusqu'à présent était le privilège
d'industriels qui seul avec ses machines
puisque ces machines industrielles
lourdes mais soudainement sur des sites
web des dizaines d'utilisateurs partager
des trucs et des astuces pour fabriquer
ses machines apprendre à s'en servir et
réaliser toutes sortes de projets
formidables
j'ai découvert ce qu'on appelle aux
états unis le meilleur movement le
meilleur movements est un phénomène
apparu en 2004 identifiés en 2004 par
dale dougherty qu'ils avaient déjà
identifié quelques années plus tôt le
web 2.0 le web du contenu généré par les
utilisateurs est le meilleur movement
c'est cette énergie cette reconnaissance
savoirs partagés par des dizaines de
bricoleur ingénieux partout sur la
planète qui sur les sujets qui les
intéressent échange avec toutes sortes
de communautés les informations des
trucs des astuces des rendez vous avec
d'autres mais coeur et tout le monde
peut être un mec heures voyez sur la
photo des mecs heures il ya des jeunes y
en a des moins jeunes il y en a des plus
vieux
il y en a dans tous les dents toutes les
sortes l'aimé coeur organisent un monde
différent
un monde où essayé est encouragée bien
sûr ou réussir n'est pas le seul
objectif et ou échouer les âmes n'est
jamais un problème parce que de ses
erreurs on apprend des choses
différentes et on peut faire des choses
différemment les make her say aussi qui
ont travaillé donc sur ces fameuses
machines à commande numérique c'est la
démocratisation de l'impression 3d s'est
largement appuyé sur le make her
movement puisque des dizaines
d'ingénieurs de bricoleurs ont commencé
à bricoler des machines qui sont devenus
les imprimantes 3d c'est avant on
appelait ça des machines de prototypage
rapide et l'impression 3d aujourd'hui
est en train de changer les choses
aujourd'hui demain le sur mesure sera
accessible à tous et la fabrication
personnalisé à la demande sera sera le
standard pour citer le professeur
lantieri de l'hôpital georges pompidou à
paris
on vit une époque formidable on vit une
époque où tout ce qu'on peut imaginer
tout ce qu'on peut décrire
on pourrait le réaliser on pourra le
fabriquer en l'occurrence il parlait
d'un poumon artificiel
aujourd'hui tout est possible le journal
mec qui est le journal du mcr movement
aux états unis en 2007 proposait de
fabriquer un cerf-volant pour faire de
la photo aérienne avec un appareil
numérique en janvier 2014
sur la couverture du magazine qui est là
la proposition c'est de fabriquer un
drone personnelles imprimées en 3d pour
faire de la vidéo et dans un numéro
récent il expliquait comment mettre en
orbite un satellite personnel
aujourd'hui c'est des pratiques des
techniques qui sont accessibles au plus
grand nombre
c'est largement documenté de nombreuses
communautés partagent des informations
pour le faire
mais aussi pour faire toutes sortes de
choses quel que soit le domaine qu'ils
soient artistiques scientifiques
culturelles de pur loisir de la
robotique de la robotique au jardinage
tout y passe aujourd'hui sur internet
tout est disponible et largement
documentée à m'écoeure faire en 2011 à
new york
maker faire c'est l'événement qui
rassemble les meilleurs du monde entier
il y en a deux comme tedx si on a deux
aux états unis comme ted une ado aux
etats unis une à new york et une à san
francisco et plusieurs centaines dans le
monde plusieurs dizaines dans le monde
pour la première fois cette année à
paris un événement où tous les meilleurs
quelles que soient leurs sujets se
réunissent et présentent leur innovation
leur création au monde entier en 2011
j'ai rencontré joe et le jeune homme qui
est en bas à droite sur la photo il
était différent
d'autre côté de l'autre droite joe et il
sa mère était inquiète
il était elle comprenait pas bien ce
qu'ils faisaient mais tout le monde le
prenait un peu au sérieux en janvier
2013 il était invité ici à la fête de la
science à la maison blanche où il a
apporté un canon à chamalot qu'il avait
fabriqué lui-même où il était très fier
que le service secret lui avait interdit
de faire fonctionner et avec lequel le
président obama a insisté pour lancer un
chamallow à travers la salle de bal de
la maison blanche et il est collé en
face d'une face de lui sur un mur sur la
tapisserie joey en octobre 2013 a été
embauché chez intel par le pdg de intel
pour s'occuper des nouveaux objets
connectés
il a été élu parmi les 10
jeunes les plus intelligents au monde en
janvier 2014 avec le président barack
obama ils ont annoncé la première maker
faire à la maison blanche en juin 2014
il sera à paris cette année au mois de
juin à la première maker faire en france
et avec joey et les autres mais coeur un
monde différent s'organise et en fait le
message aujourd'hui c'est que vous êtes
sans doute tous des meilleurs des
meilleurs qui comme monsieur jourdain
faisait de la poésie s'ignorent réaliser
le vous faites sans doute des choses
extraordinaires
il ya sans doute autour de vous des gens
avec qui partager ces choses où il ya
sans doute autour de vous des gens qui
font des choses extraordinaires
rapprochez-vous 2 comme dirait joey il à
sa devise dont le big board make
something ne vous ennuyez pas fait
quelque chose
soyez différents soyez des mecs heures
merci bonne journée